can you talk about
because i know you got to get out of
here the rock nathan the roc nation guy
is waving waving at me the
man with the ponytail um real quick man
because i
i think uh it's important for anyone
who's listening or watching this to kind
of
for inspirational purposes man you you
know i just saw your daughters like
going to college
right like you're a [ __ ] father
you're
um i want i want you to kind of give me
you know your take on the perseverance
that it took for you to get to this
point because i think a lot of people
look at you as a new artist and look at
you
like man like you're a grown ass man
with real ass responsibilities in this
world
and like you're just hitting your peak
and
i think a lot of people they're
they're in it for the quick nut and once
something doesn't happen that they
expect to happen as quick as they'd like
it to happen they give up and they walk
away and
question what they do like like your
career
as a whole kind of you know what what
drove you the whole time man and like
just my hunger for it and uh
knowing i had the talent i always felt
the responsibility to my talent
because even when i was in and out of
jail or even i was on
corners trapping or even i was serving
[ __ ] who who wanted to who was my fans
like yo man you still rapping and i'm
like damn i was just in the studio
earlier [ __ ] asking me am i still
rapping
and i thought i had [ __ ] on lock you
know what i'm saying in town when they
asked me is i'm still rapping
so i always felt that i always had to
answer that and i
feel like uh fire as my perseverance
and everything it's like people here
hear it but they don't they don't really
take it for what it's worth everybody
want to do the cute [ __ ]
nobody literally want to get in this
game have discipline
you from them saying discipline
themselves and learn the business you
know what i'm saying that's the hard
part nobody want to do [ __ ]
these [ __ ] selling all these records
they still don't know the business they
don't know they still don't know [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
get on tv and they look like experts
these these [ __ ] don't know nothing so
i did everything step by step because i
couldn't
get in the records from drake and push
and all them [ __ ] in that
wayne that wasn't an option for me
always so ah you had to earn that
exactly exactly so i did it step by step
i really did it the hard way and you
know dudes don't want to do it no more
but it's the most
that's the most valuable way to do it
because
uh it's always going to be there if you
put a brick on top of a brick that's
what i'm saying is still you're going to
go
exactly so it was like this is something
physical
when i when i know what i'm doing this
is physical because the knowledge never
go nowhere you know what i'm saying
the experience that you got from that
hard work can never go nowhere
and i feel like i just had the
discipline and i tell
i tell my team that like the number one
thing is
you got to have discipline not enough to
to hang around those dudes who want to
get you on some [ __ ] when you can't
be here
you got to have enough discipline not to
take the easy money over here when they
offering it to you
you got to have a discipline and not to
be over here [ __ ] with these [ __ ]
over here instagram [ __ ] screenshot
your messages and all that weird [ __ ]
you gotta have discipline in this game
and that'll get you fired